the movie is set in the year 3000 A.D
where a deadly species of humanoid
aliens known as the cyclos have taken
control over the Earth in fact it has
been a millennium since the Earth was
taken over almost all of the villages
and cities worldwide are decimated and
humans have become a rare species now
they are either enslaved by the cyclos
or live in caves as isolated tribes
cyclos have also taken all the valuable
resources from the planet and now they
are in search of gold as for the
remaining humans living in caves they
have lost all hope of regaining their
control over Earth at the start of the
movie A tribesman named Johnny arrives
home with medicine for his ill father
but he realizes that it's too late
devastated he approaches their group's
leader and suggests they shift their
location to a new place as food and
water supply is running out quickly here
we get to know that the tribe's people
have been living in the cave for almost
two centuries and they have never seen
the outside world they know that danger
lies ahead but don't know exactly what
it as a result the leader refuses to
shift their location fearing that they
will be attacked by the gods hearing
this Johnny who is an atheist becomes
angry and decides to find a new
settlement area by himself he then gets
on his horse and starts his journey on
his way out his girlfriend Chrissy tries
to stop him but Johnny defies her
request and rides away after a few hours
of traveling Johnny reaches a green
forest and decides to explore when he
comes across some man-made statues he
mistakes them for aliens and gets scared
but when he checks them closely he gets
to know that they're just artifacts just
then Johnny is confronted by a couple of
hunters Carlo and rock who are surprised
to see another human Carlo tells Johnny
that he should thank God for keeping him
alive but Johnny being a non-believer
says no instead he offers them some food
if they can show him the evidence of
God's existence the two Hunters gladly
agree and take Johnny around the city's
ruins to show him other statues they
claim that the statues were once human
until they were punished by God for for
their wrong Deeds later at night the
three set their Camp inside a
dilapidated building and start eating as
the three share stories of their Village
a cyclos alien arrives there and attacks
them the humans try their best to escape
but they are eventually caught and
locked inside a cage Johnny looks around
and notices other humans like them
inside the cage soon the group is
transported to the aliens base in Denver
Colorado since the aliens cannot breathe
properly in Earth's atmosphere they have
built a massive Dome to adjust the
atmosphere as their home planet as a
result every human entering there should
wear a pipe-like device around their
nose to be able to breathe and it is
just the opposite for the cyclos they
need to wear those pipes whenever they
leave their base as soon as the group
lands Carlo tries to escape but an alien
shoots him down with his God seeing this
Johnny snatches the weapon and takes one
of them down he also tries to run away
and even manages to reach far but sadly
gets caught by the security head of the
base turtle turtle drags Johnny to the
place where he shot the alien and asks
every everyone how a human can operate a
gun it turns out that the cyclos look
upon humans as a dumb species who cannot
operate any complex Machinery to confirm
his doubts Turtle hands over a gun to
Johnny and asks him to shoot another
guard and surprisingly he does it again
this leaves Turtle stunned perhaps the
dumb one is the guy who just armed his
opponent in the next scene zet a senior
officer from the cyclos home planet
teleports himself to the Earth to
conduct an important meeting with the
Earth officials turtle is excited to end
his tenure of service on Earth and
proposes to return to his home planet he
also mentions that his assistant Kerr is
eager to take his place however zeit
informs him that the company has decided
to keep turtle on Earth for the next 50
Cycles not only that he has to start
extracting the remaining gold from Earth
as soon as possible unsurprisingly
turtle is angry about the decision but
he can do nothing more than remains
silent on the other hand the captured
humans are locked inside a cell and are
treated like slaves they are then served
with gooey green food Floyd one of the
bullies inside the cell threatens
everyone that he and his gang will have
the food first and if anything Remains
the others can have it however Johnny
who is already sick of being controlled
by others decides to revolt soon a fight
breaks out between the two and Johnny
emerges Victorious he then declares that
everyone can have their food in equal
proportion and dismisses the idea of a
hierarchy meanwhile Turtle goes to meet
his assistant Kerr and finds him hiding
an important file curious he asks about
it and the latter replies that the file
contains pictures of a place from which
they can extract gold but they will not
be able to invade the place because
their breathing pipes won't work there
hearing this Turtle becomes angry and
accuses Kerr of trying to steal the gold
all by himself after punishing his
assistant he then devises a plan where
the human slaves will extract the gold
for them later he approaches their
senior officer planetship and proposes
the idea to him however the latter
immediately refuses claiming that it is
a violation of their company's rules the
next day when the humans are being
transported to their workplace Johnny
again tries to escape but just like the
last time he is caught as a punishment
the aliens removed Johnny's breathing
device and to leave him to die
fortunately one of the human slaves
notices him and saves his life meanwhile
turtle and kerr plan about training
humans and using them to extract the
Gold without their company knowing about
it elsewhere Johnny arrives at the end
of the cyclos base but finds the exit
door locked to make matters worse two
cyclist officers arrive and confront him
turtle and kerr also enter The Fray and
seeing Johnny's anger and energy they
decide to let him go out and learn more
about humans for the sake of their evil
plan that evening they set Johnny and
two other humans free with cameras on
their jackets later the trio starts
walking away from the base believing
that they are now free they walk for
some time in the freezing weather and
decide to rest in a destroyed building
for food they hunt some rats and eat
them raw all this time turtle and Kura
are keeping an eye on them with the
cameras unfortunately for them the boys
also discover the cameras in their
jackets and remove them immediately as a
result Turtle sends his men to catch
Johnny and the others a Chase ensues for
a while but the humans are eventually
captured and brought back to the base at
least they got to eat rat while they
were out following this an enraged
Turtle takes Johnny inside a secret room
ties him to a chair and uses an advanced
machine to impart the cyclos's knowledge
into him it turns out that turtle is
doing all this so that Johnny can learn
their language and be able to extract
gold on his own the plan works and
unbeknownst to Turtle he learns several
things like how to use weapons how to
fly aircraft the history of the cyclos
and so on later at night Johnny tries to
share his cyclist knowledge with other
humans explaining that they can use it
to destroy the aliens once and for all
but as expected none of them can
understand anything despite this Johnny
declares that one day humans will
overthrow the cyclos and retake their
Planet elsewhere as Johnny has not
returned home for a couple of days his
wife from the tribe Chrissy sets off in
search of M the next day an impatient
Turtle brings Johnny to his room and
inquires about what he has learned so
far surprisingly the human replies in
cyclos language which makes Turtle
surprised and happy at the same time he
then takes Johnny to the ruined Public
Library of Denver and boasts that in
early 21st century the cyclos conquered
all of Earth in a mere nine minutes as
Johnny reads a book he comes across the
topic Independence and becomes more
focused on liberating Earth from the
aliens he then agrees to extract gold
but in return demands the safety of
other humans inside the Dome Turtle
complies to his demands and soon takes
Johnny and several other humans to the
mining location unfortunately while
turtle is briefing the group about the
mining process another tribe of humans
appears out of nowhere and attacks the
aliens Terrell is immediately subdued
and Johnny gets the chance to kill him
but he doesn't he stops the tribe and
explains that if they kill Turtle the
other humans inside their base will also
get killed later Turtle takes Johnny
away and reveals that they have captured
Chris he identified her as Johnny's
Lover by finding his picture in her
possession the terrified girl is wearing
a device around her neck that can be
blown up by the push of a button seeing
this a devastated Johnny vous to carry
out his duties with more seriousness at
night back to the cage Johnny talks with
the human group and assures them that he
knows the language of the cyclos and is
making a plan to eradicate them from
Earth he then delivers a motivational
speech prompting everyone to pledge
their alliances to him meanwhile turtle
and Curry meet a female cyclos and
secretly trade some information about
planetship's accounts after studying the
information Turtle gets to know that
planetship has been falsely reporting to
their seniors that their operations on
earth have yielded a loss he does this
so that he can keep the profit for
himself using this as leverage Turtle
blackmails Planet ship and makes him
sign an agreement to allow the use of
humans for gold mining now with
planetship out of the way he starts
teaching Johnny how to fly their ship
and use their weapons in the next scene
Turtle takes the group to the mining
site and starts giving them instructions
he mentions that he will return after 14
days and by that time they must have
mined half of the gold present there
after Turtle leaves Johnny tells the
group that they do not need to mine gold
as there is already enough present
inside a nearby Fort it turns out that
Johnny studied about Fort Knox before he
arrived on the mission he also explains
that they need to finish off the aliens
and to destroy their home planet so that
Earth will never be captured again after
14 days Johnny presents the gold bars to
Turtle which they have retrieved from
Fort Knox at first turtle is skeptical
as the gold is in the form of bars but
when he checks thoroughly he approves he
then orders Johnny to mine the rest of
the gold in seven days later using the
cyclist Transportation ship Johnny takes
his crew to the U.S military fort in
Texas and starts Gathering the weapons
present there inside the fort they also
find fighter jets and a nuclear bomb
Johnny tries to activate the bomb but
fails due to the lack of knowledge just
then one of the humans Mickey turns on a
projector displaying the information
about the nuclear mom's activation
realizing that the bomb is the perfect
weapon to destroy the cyclosis planet
Johnny decides to use it the plan is to
enter the alien's teleportation device
reach their planet and destroy it with
the nuclear bomb but just then Maki
tells everyone that he wants to do it
instead as Johnny has to lead the
revolution on Earth after returning to
the base Johnny approaches Kerr and
provokes him he reveals that turtle is
planning to fly away to his home planet
with all of the gold surprisingly Kerr
believes it and Johnny puts forward a
deal he proposes that he will help Kerr
get rid of turtle but in return all of
the humans should be freed obliging to
the deal Kerr releases all the humans
and Johnny is finally reconciled with
his lover Chrissy unfortunately after a
while Turtle gets wind of his assistance
betrayal and blows off one of his hands
as punishment before leaving he also
orders Kerr to manage the teleportation
device for his departure to the home
planet on the other hand the humans are
getting ready for the attack Carlo who
has been instrumental in their
preparations is seen with some
explosives he constantly tries to
contact Johnny for permission to fire
but fails his situation turns even worse
when some alien warships surround him it
appears as if Carlo is doomed but just
then other humans arrive with fighter
planes which they had retrieved from
Fort Knox with this a brutal fight
ensues between the two parties on the
ground the humans and cyclists fight
with their weapons while in the air the
warships and fighter jets tussle amidst
the chaos Johnny leads Mickey and the
nuclear bomb to the control room where
the teleportation device is present
after a bit of a struggle he
successfully reboots the device and
signals Carlo to attack the Dome the
latter obliges and detonates a number of
explosives at the Dome unfortunately
even all the Firepower is unable to
destroy the glass surrounding the Dome
frustrated for failing in his first
attempt Carlo boards an alien warship
and decides to strike the Dome his plan
however fails terribly when he gets
stuck into the glass frame now with time
running out and the cyclos slowly
gaining an upper hand in the battle
Carlo starts looking desperately for a 1
way out fortunately he finds some
explosives inside the ship and gets an
idea he picks up a missile launcher and
blows up the warship in the name of
Earth even if it costs him his life this
results in a huge explosion and the
alien's Dome starts crumbling down to
the ground making it difficult for the
cyclos to breathe despite this Turtle
finds Johnny inside the control room and
apprehends him he then orders his army
to kill every human on site just then
Johnny attacks turtle and secretly locks
the weapon that he took off from
Chrissy's neck earlier he then pleads
with Turtle for his wife's life and
instigates him in detonating the weapon
Turtle falls into the Trap and activates
the weapon blowing off his own hand by
this time the teleportation device is
already activated and Mickey and the
nuclear bomb are transported to the
cyclos home planet as soon as he reaches
there he detonates the nuclear bomb
engulfing the whole planet and also
sacrificing himself in the process the
next morning on Earth the remaining
humans have finally become free from the
tyrannical rule of the cyclos cut to
several months later although humans
have retaken the Earth mankind still
faces a precarious future they still
fear that the cyclos living on other
planets can launch an attack it turns
out that the cyclists have been the
dominant species across multiple
universes for at least 100 000 years and
this is the first time they were
defeated hard to believe given how
stupid they are as the movie ends we are
shown that turtle is held captive inside
Fort Knox while kurz joined the humans
as a scientist now the rejuvenated
humans plan to rebuild their
civilization again subscribe for more
videos like this turn on notifications
and leave a like to help the channel out
thank you for watching